salut tout le monde donc je fais une
petite vidéo rapide pour vous annoncer
la sortie du site internet comme je vous
avais dit sur
joueurdugrenier.fr alors ne vous
inquiétez pas les vidéos seront toujours
diffusées sur Youtube et sur Dailymotion
ça ça changera pas par contre
l'avancement de la vidéo et les news
vont disparaître du profil pour passer
sur le site ce qui sera vachement plus
pratique pour moi sur le site je
posterai régulièrement des news sur la
vidéo en cours et peut-être même des
indices sur les prochaines vidéos bon
alà autre chose il y a énormément de
questions qui me sont posées je pense
sur les messages privés sur les
commentaires des vidéos sur le profil
donc on va essayer de centraliser un peu
tout ça parce que je peux pas me balader
partout en permanence et donc c'est vous
verrez que en haut du site en haut de la
page il y a un lien vers le forum de
prstart bouton donc ça sera le forum de
joueurs du grenier j'y passerai
régulièrement d'ailleurs au passage je
précise bien que le login du site n'a
rien à voir avec le login du forum hein
il faut vous inscrire sur le site de
prestard bouton pour pouvoir y poster
sur le forum d'ailleurs sur ce forum
vous verrez j'ai déjà créé deux sujets
le premier c'est pour les suggestions de
jeu parce que j'en reçois j'en reçois de
partout mais il y a tellement que c'est
difficile j'essaie noté au fur à mesure
mais c'est vraiment galère donc même si
vous les avez déjà proposé même si vous
les avez déjà dites remettez-les sur le
forum comme ça c'est plus facile à gérer
comme ça je peux avoir une liste plus
facilement et le deuxième donc c'est
pour les questions et là je ferai une
vidéo dans dans pas longtemps où je
sélectionnerai les questions les plus
fréquentes pour y répondre à travers une
vidéo ça sera plus facile pour moi parce
que sur comm ça j'aurais pas besoin de
le répéter à chaque fois voilà donc j'ai
déjà abordé le sujet un peu mais là
notre matériel commence très
sérieusement à se fatiguer je veux dire
notre pied caméra il qui avec un clou et
un morceau de pâ fixe pour vous dire le
micro il sature dès que j'urle un peu
trop fort le zoom de la caméra il est
foutu le fond bleu il est dégueulasse
enfin donc j'ai mis un lien Paypal pour
les gens qui seraient éventuellement
prêts à nous aider enfin je veux dire
maintenant vous êtes tellement nombreux
il suffirait que ne serait-ce qu'une
personne sur 100 participe et on aurait
largement de quoi changer le matos donc
ben écoutez d'avance je vous remercie
voilà donc n'oubliez pas de poster sur
le forum et sur joueurdugrenier.fr et
rendez-vous dans 2 semaines pour la
prochaine vidéo hors série sur les
dessins animés
[Musique]